bonjour à tous je suis ses couilles la
tac tac
aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'un
sujet important que les économistes
évoquent souvent à la télévision
je vais vous parler du chiffre battant
alors c'est quoi le chiffre d'affaires
le chiffre d'affaires correspond pour
nous total des encaissements sans frais
ou tout simplement tout l'argent
rentrant dans le couple de l'entreprise
il se calcule toujours hors taxes il
s'agit d' où l' d'additionner l'ensemble
des ventes et où prestations de services
par exemple imaginons que vous avez
pondu un article à 30 euros hors taxe et
un article à 40 euros hors taxes votre
chiffres d'apple et 2,40 plus trop ce
soit 70 euros hors taxes le calcul de
son chiffre d'affaires est un élément
ils sont fiers en effet lorsque l'on
créé son entreprise
le chiffre d'affaires est un indicateur
important dans l'évolution de la société
le chiffre d'affaires permet-il
d'évaluer une entreprise à nice elle les
chiffres d'affaires ne permet pas
d'évaluer l'entreprise son niveau dépend
en effet de la nature de son activité
cette tendance est un outil de
comparaison trafic entre entreprises
d'un même secteur d'activité pour but i
liste on le chiffre d'affaires le
chiffre d'affaires est utilisé dans tout
ce qui touche à la comptabilité
généralement dans une entreprise c'est
par des calculs les plus importants il
est plus vivant dans chaque bureau qu'il
se charge de faire le calcul est en
général c'est qui s'occupe de la
comptabilité d'entreprise pour une
utilisation optimale
il est préférable d'observer la
progression du chiffre d'affaires par
mois ou par période de la même façon il
peut être intéressant de faire une étude
de l'évolution du chiffre d'affaires par
ce produit avant de pouvoir réorienter
son activité vers des marchés plus
lucratifs quelle est l'utilité pour
l'entreprise de suivre le chiffre
d'affaires des points sont importants
dans les suivis de son chiffre
d'affaires les performances des
entreprises du même secteur d'activité
comparer son chiffre d'affaires avec
celui d'autres entreprises permet
d'avoir une idée de ses performances et
de la situation de son activité
l'évolution des charges si le chiffre
d'affaires
croît rapidement c'est là peut-être
signes de forte performance pourtant si
parallèlement les charges explosent la
volonté d'augmenter le chiffre
d'affaires aura été préjudiciables pour
l'entreprise
comment arriver un meilleur chiffre
d'affaires au pouvoir fait progresser
son chiffre d'affaires il faudra donc
pouvoir faire varier ses trois
composantes le volume le nombre de
piment et la crise quelle est la
différence entre le chiffre d'affaires
et le bénéfice de l'entreprise
le chiffre d'affaires aussi à quelle
recette dont le langage kourou et à la
poutre avec le bénéfice d'une entreprise
d'ailleurs il m'est arrivé la theurre de
réussite de l'entreprise c'est le
bénéfice qui montre si l'entreprise se
porte bien
concrètement le chiffre d'affaires c'est
le montant total des biens vendus tandis
que le bénéfice correspond au chiffre
d'affaires - les charges de l'entreprise
c'est-à-dire moins les dépenses liées au
paiement des salaires des impôts ou de
l'achat de matières premières par
exemple
j'espère que vous avez bien compris ce
qu'est le chiffre d'affaires je vous dis
à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode